veamos si podemos tener un poquito más
de intuición y de práctica con
ejercicios de masa así que voy a
resolver algunos problemas aritméticos
que se encuentran en kant academy y este
dice así dice que masa es la más cercana
a la masa de una oruga y nos dan dos
opciones la primera de ellas es tres
gramos y la segunda de ellas son 300
gramos ok entonces tenemos que ponernos
a meditar cuál sería la masa más cercana
de esta pequeña oruga que tenemos aquí y
si por ejemplo pensamos en tres gramos
bueno uno podría decir pues tiene
sentido la oruga lo mejor es muy pequeña
a lo mejor tiene más o menos la masa
digamos de un clip o de un de un lápiz
por ejemplo verdad sin embargo si nos
ponemos a pensar en 300 gramos 300
gramos pueden ser más o menos digamos la
masa que tiene un pequeño gato un gato
recién nacido tal vez y definitivamente
un gato recién nacido es mucho más
grande que esta oruga verdad
nuestra nuestra opción más adecuada
serían 3 gramos muy bien vamos a
comprobar y está correcto vamos con otra
dice nikita pide prestados tres libros
de superhéroes y un libro de dragones de
la biblioteca cada libro de superhéroes
tiene una masa de 200 gramos verdad y
tenemos tres cada libro de dragones
tiene una masa de 310 gramos cual es la
masa de los libros que nikita pidió
prestados y bueno aquí tenemos tres
libros de superhéroes y cada uno tiene
una masa de 200 gramos así que si
queremos saber la masa total de los
libros de superhéroes tendríamos que
multiplicar 3 por 200 y eso nos da 600
verdad 600 pero hay que tener cuidado
además nikita llevo un libro de dragones
de la biblioteca verdad y ese tiene una
masa de 310 gramos así que a 600 hay que
agregarle 310 cuántos serían 600 más 310
bueno sería
digamos sería 910 verdad tendríamos 910
vamos a comprobar y es correcto vamos
con la siguiente dice en el acuario hay
cuatro focas adultas y dos focas bebé
las cuatro focas adultas tienen la misma
masa cada una también las dos focas bebé
tienen la misma masa cada una por
supuesto dice que las masas de una foca
adulta y una foca de bebé se muestran
abajo justamente en esta imagen cual es
la masa de las focas en el acuario muy
bien y aquí nos dice que la foca adulta
verdad tiene 120 kilogramos que es
bastante tiene tiene bastante masa de
esta foca y tenemos 4 así que cuanto
sería la masa total de las focas adultas
veamos tendríamos que multiplicar 120
por cuatro verdad cuánto es 120 por
cuatro bueno sería 4 por ejemplo 4 por 0
sería 0
2 x 4 sería 8 y 4 por 1 sería 4 verdad
así que 480 kilogramos hay digamos de
focas adultas verdad y además tenemos
dos pocas bebé dos focas bebé y cada una
tiene una masa de 35 kilogramos así que
si multiplicamos 2 x 35 nos da 70 70
verdad así que tenemos que hacer esta
suma para saber cuál es la masa total de
las focas verdad y 400 es perdón 480 más
70 serían bueno tendríamos
pero verdad vamos a vamos a hacerlo con
cuidado lo voy a escribir aquí por
ejemplo si sumamos las unidades
tendríamos 0 7 y 8 serían 15 verdad y
llevamos una centena y sólo tenemos 4
centenas más una que llega llevamos
serían 5 verdad entonces la respuesta
serían 550 kilogramos vamos a comprobar
y es correcto vamos con otro más dice
que masa es la más cercana a la masa de
un ratón serían 20 gramos o 20
kilogramos y bueno definitivamente creo
que 20 kilogramos es una exageración
para la masa de un ratón verdad tendré
que ser sumamente grande este ratón
porque por ejemplo pues no sé quizás si
has acompañado a tus papás al
supermercado sabrás que una bolsa de
arroz por ejemplo de si puede ser de
arroz tiene una masa de un kilogramo y
es bastante pesado quizás para un ratón
verdad así que nuestra opción serían 20
gramos
vamos con una última dice computerworld
manda una caja por correo con una masa
total de 40 kilogramos hay 10 monitores
de computadora en la caja verdad luego
nos dice todos los monitores tienen la
misma masa cuál es la masa de uno de los
monitores de computadora entonces
tenemos la caja que tiene una masa de 40
kilogramos y dentro hay 10 monitores
verdad quiere decir que si queremos
saber la masa de cada monitor tendríamos
que dividir 40 kilogramos entre 10
monitores verdad eso nos da un total de
40 entre 10 nos da 4 kilogramos